hello everyone and welcome to Game two
of the magnus carlsen invitational now
we are continuing the match all it is a
Fallujah versus Magnus cross and the
first game was won by Magnus and it was
quite the game and now a Larissa if he
wants to get back into the match he
should definitely retaliate although
against the world champion that that's
easier said than done so without further
ado let's check out the game we have a
four by Fallujah and Carlson sticks with
his Sicilian we see five and now not
Knight to c3 like a Fallujah went in the
batter blitz cover but instead and
Knight to f3
we have Knight to c6 and Bishop to b5
future goes for the arrow Salim Oh
attack we have E six by Magnus and now
Bishop characters and see sex with B
captures and now d3 we have Queen to c7
by Magnus are now preparing to close the
position completely with E 5 we have
Queen e2 with ideas of pushing 5 himself
and now of course II five and here
Knight B to d2 and already as of move
seven we have a completely new game so
Knights the e7 by Magnus he wants to
shift the night over to g6 to help out
with the defense of the pawn here we
have 9th to see for now blockading both
of these pawns and the keeping an eye on
the e5 pawn so nigh g6 defending and now
h4 fallujah wants to kick away the night
to win the pawn here so Magnus defends
it with h5 and just g3 we have d6 by
Magnus and Bishop to d2 now I just
continuing development and f6 now
further strengthening the pawn at some
point in the future you of course will
be interested in pushing d5 so you want
to d5 pawn protected we have Knight the
e3 now now the knight can be shifted
over to f5 but it's just a nice
centralized square so Bishop to e7 and
now Knight the g1 and here both players
started to go into some crazy
maneuvering here future ones that
shifted the knight over to c3 and he
doesn't allow Carson to develop with
Bishop to g4 now if Bishop to g4 you can
just kick it away with f3 or just pick
it up with the knight but all in all
this night is coming
all the way to C 3 we have Bishop to d8
by Magnus and now Queen to f3 making
room for the night we have night the f8
going to over to e6 from where you will
control D 4 and therefore night Stewie
to end now of course knife to East 6 we
have Queen to g2 now not allowing nights
to d4 to come with an attack on the
Queen but also making room for DF pawn
to start marching forward with a 5 and
fallujah prevents the point from being
pushed forward with a 4 as an a5 it
could remain a target and it's not not
usual that you will see a position with
both a 4h for a 5 and H 5 on the board
so very very interesting and a Larissa
continues a magnus continues with
Knights to d4 an excellent outpost for
tonight and the ladies are continues
with f4 we have the ship the e6 by
Magnus now gaining more control of the
d5 square and just be three so nicely
keeping everything under control
Queen to d7 now Magnus if possible wants
to push f5 and the bust open the
position like this so ali riza prevents
it he pushes the 5 himself and now just
Bishop back to f7 and now Knight the c1
now shifting the night overturn maybe a
2 and then c3 but also just preparing
the castle in the just making room for
the Queen
so d5 by black and now that everything
has been everything has been done nicely
and both the King side and the Queen
side have been completely blocked and
now for the further every Sicilian
players dream black execute d5 we have
castles by fuchsia and now even c4 I
showed the knife from c1 now nicely
nicely protected b3 and d3
we have me captures on c4 b captures on
c4 d captures and C for Enda now D
captures on c4 so here if you lose your
wanna pawn but cousin will get a lot of
development in with Bishop to b6 getting
the bishop over to this nice diagonal
and rook the b1 now
attacking the bishop we have Queen to a7
now with some very nasty discoveries for
example you could pick up the the c2
pawn and open up the attack towards the
king
so King the h2 getting the King carted
away and the now just worked the d8
continuing to bring more pieces into the
attack the the Bishop will also be
attacked if the knight moves so rook the
b2 now with more defense of the b2 pawn
so now the knight can move from e3 we
have castles bye-bye Magnus and now
without thinking twice holidays that
goes for g4 he wants to open up the
position maybe get the roof to g1 start
an attack against against cousins King
so night the e2 sorry nice T to buy
Magnus and this is a very very
interesting idea he doesn't want to
capture on g4 and then went back to
spawn but rather for example you could
go for H captures and then if Knight
captures you could win back the c4 pawn
but he instead finds Knight to e2 and
it's quite an interesting trick because
now it blocks the Queen's defense of the
bishop so rook captures Bishop is is the
idea here but also there's a double
attack on the knight now but the knight
is hanging here so Ali Riza picks it up
Queen captures and now Magnus goes for
rook captures and d2 he sacrifices the
exchange we have Queen captures on d2
and now Bishop captures on e3 attacking
the Queen Quinta e 2 and now Queen to d4
with a double attack here so definitely
definitely worth the the exchange
sacrifice Knights the d3 defending the
rook and now Queen captures on e4 we
have worked
II won of hoping to win the bishop here
but now Bishop the f4 with check
algorithm moves the king and now Queen
captures on c4 and here G captures on h5
just the opening up the G file and now
Magnus goes back Bishop to h6 not
allowing this knife the captured a
bishop in the future but also to prevent
this pawn from being pushed forward and
the
will X lead offended the g-seven pawn so
rook the b7 Fallujah gets more more
pieces into the attack and now Magnus
just calmly grabs yet another pawn so
here it's five points the for now it's
Magnus who's up upon but rook the g1 so
now there's a lot of pressure at words
crossing skin but the bishop on h6 just
does an excellent the job of defending
we looked d8 by Magnus now if the knight
moves you will be able to shift the rook
over to d2 rook the g3 by fuchsia and
now comes Queen to a one probably rook
the d4 is also an idea going after h4
but you could block it would work to g4
then if rook the d4 as the Queen also
covers g4
so instead Magnus goes for Queen to a-1
he wants to go over to the h1 square and
now comes a move that Magnus surely
didn't expect he was probably expecting
the Queen to guard with Queen to g2 but
oh it is a place the incredible Knights
the f2 now blocking the h1 square
however he allows rook to d2 to attack
both of the Queen in the night and this
is what crossing plays immediately but
there is a problem to this fuchsia plays
rook to b8 check we have king to h7 and
the now comes Queen to g4 here Alireza
offers a night here and Magnus not
interested in grabbing the knight right
away first he goes Quinta f1 width check
and of course not talking to h2 then a
route captors comes with check here ali
reza plays rook to g2 and unbelievable
unbelievable as it is here at Magnus
gives up the Queen with Queen captures
and g2 and now King captures and g2 and
it was also in this position that Magnus
Carlsen resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here he's down a
queen and it's it's completely lost now
if you're wondering why Magnus gave up
the Queen the problem is after this rip
the g2 move yes you could
for example win the night here but the
problem is after rook captures an f2 do
you see how allah reza wins the game
even feel free to pause the video and
try to find the idea
I'll give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations
unsporting yet another Queen sacrifice
in their match and for those who just
want to enjoy the show
yes it's Queen to g6 check and even
though the bishop is doing a wonderful
job guarding the g7 pawn sometimes even
that doesn't matter here you have to
capture the Queen and mount either
capture will result in checkmate as the
rook prevents the king from escaping to
the back rank so if you're wondering
where was Carlson's mistake it was
actually in this moment where ali reza
was able to trick him queen a 1 goes
after the h1 square knights the f2
seemingly blundering rook to d2 but in
fact it was it was a genius genius
deception which Carlson did not spot so
here you would have to just ignore it
not not allow rook to b8 check this is
very important as long as the white
doesn't have the rook on the back rank
then it's all it's all just good for
example Queen the c1 you just play a
normal move and the game just continues
with Carson being better of course he
does have a past a pawn and ended the
bishop pair so now should be a nice
position for him however he went for
rook to be - and now the incredible Ruby
check here and now Queen g4 threatening
this and now it's reasonable there's
nothing you can do here whatever you do
Queen g6 is coming and you cannot
prevent it but yeah I cross and decided
to give up the Queen and then after King
captures and g2 it was only here that he
resigned the game yeah that's a game to
Fallujah retaliates and the match is now
set at one point each and we're for of
course going to continue and see who
emerges victorious and we will we go to
Armageddon so I do hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank feel like eventual
to insta marketing's Everett Mulder
Joshua not and Lauren there for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
Magnus invitational most likely until it
finishes thank you I will see you soon
into heaven
the rest of your day